[Musica]
parlerò di questo argomento estremamente
complesso che sono i processi cognitivi
umani e la memoria e
noi siamo per esempio bombardati
quotidianamente da una quantità enorme
di informazioni
queste informazioni sono in questo
momento tutte relative al co vidal a
questo tipo di pandemia che abbiamo a
cui assistiamo che cosa succede succede
che noi di solito queste informazioni
le più varie con versioni diverse
eccetera fondamentalmente le ignoriamo e
prendiamo soltanto gli elementi che per
noi sono fondamentali e in base a questi
poi noi valutiamo la situazione e
decidiamo anche i nostri comportamenti
decidiamo mascherina si mascherina no
distanziamento sociale si distanziamento
sociale no e questo perché non è
necessariamente una colpa certamente può
creare dei problemi se uno non porta
alla mascherina nel momento giusto
oppure se non distanze adeguatamente
dall'altro nel momento in cui potrebbe
essere contagiato
ma questo succede perché normalmente il
sistema cognitivo umano predilige tra la
semplicità e la complessità predilige la
semplicità e predilige la semplicità per
un motivo molto semplice perché il
pensiero complesso è un pensiero che
richiede risorse è un pensiero che
utilizza risorse cognitive le risorse
cognitive non sono infinite ne abbiamo
una quantità relativamente limitata e
quindi il sistema cognitivo sceglie tra
le varie possibilità
il tipo di pensiero il tipo di
ragionamento il tipo di soluzione che è
la più semplice la più immediata
quando parliamo di questi due sistemi di
pensiero pensiero complesso pensiero
semplice in realtà tutto sommato ci
possiamo riferire a una divisione che
era stata già operata in maniera
scientifica da daniel cane man premio
nobel per l'economia
uno dei due premi nobel per l'economia
per ricerche in psicologia il quale
aveva distinto un pensiero lento che per
l'appunto il pensiero complesso e questo
pensiero lento e lenta perché perché è
sistematico e analitico prende in esame
tutti gli elementi di una situazione di
valuta li soppesa e poi arriva una
decisione
questo è un sistema intenzionale ed è un
sistema estremamente potente è un
sistema estremamente potente che ci può
portare a soluzioni incredibile come per
esempio appunto ci ha portato cia ha
portato l'uomo a poter mandare una sonda
spaziale su marte poter mandare il un
drone che è riuscito a sollevarsi dal
dal pianeta dal suolo a marte però
appunto è un sistema che è impegnativo e
allora quotidianamente qual è il tipo di
pensiero che viene usato è un tipo di
pensiero in realtà semplice un pensiero
rapido è un pensiero che utilizza
scorciatoie è un pensiero di tipo
intuitivo e un pensiero di tipo
inconsapevole nel senso che noi
arriviamo a raggiunge delle conclusioni
a valutare delle situazioni senza sapere
perché ci arriviamo e senza avere
consapevolezza dei momenti delle tappe
che utilizziamo nella arrivare a queste
conclusioni
è questo tipo di pensiero è basato su
precedenti nel senso che se noi dobbiamo
per esempio decidere quanto siamo
disponibili a prendere un aereo dopo
aver ricevuto informazioni positive di
questo tipo siamo molto più propensi a
appunto a prenderla ero rispetto a
situazioni in cui invece a ci presentano
informazioni negative sulla pericolosità
del prendere l'aereo
chiunque di noi nella in queste
condizioni darebbe delle risposte di
tipo diversa ma questo sistema di
pensiero è un pensiero un sistema di
pensiero anche estremamente potente nel
senso che è un sistema di pensiero che
ci permette di negoziare la realtà tutti
i giorni è quel sistema di pensiero che
ci permette per esempio di
interagire col prossimo leggendo
l'emozione nel prossimo non soltanto un
emozioni così visibili come per esempio
la rabbia di di questo primo di questa
prima persona ma anche emozioni
estremamente più sottili come per
esempio la perplessità negli occhi di
questa persona seconda persona ed è un
sistema così potente perché ci permette
di prendere decisioni rapidissime e la
nostra vita la nostra sopravvivenza
dipendono da queste decisioni
rapidissime quindi evviva il pensiero
semplice il problema che il pensiero
semplice in realtà ci dà anche degli
errori e questi errori sono visibili per
esempio nella nostra superficialità nel
comprendere affermazioni del tipo la
variante indiana del sar scott 19 e più
pericolosa
non è lo prendiamo così al face value
per per quello che vale e ci crediamo
senza chiederci cosa si intende con
pericolosità senza chiederci cosa si
intende con più cioè più pericolosa di
che cosa di quali altre varianti di
quali altre situazioni lo stesso tipo di
pensiero semplice è quello che ci porta
ad accettare per quello per come vero
un'affermazione del tipo aiutiamoli a
casa loro riferito ai migranti ma per
capire effettivamente un'affermazione
del genere uno deve capire quali
migranti da quali paesi con quali
esigenze con quali motivazioni quali
mezzi abbiamo per aiutarli quindi per
capire anche affermazioni quotidiane di
questo tipo in realtà abbiamo bisogno
dell'intervento del sistema di un
sistema complesso il sistema semplice
questo sistema 1 questo sistema rapido
ci porta a fare errori e la ricerca in
psicologia in realtà ha illustrato
moltissime degli errori che vengono
fatti le fallace della logica per
esempio è proprio gli errori di base che
vengono fatti poi che vengono fatti
nelle decisioni
e lo stesso tipo di sistema di pensiero
semplice e rapido e quello che poi ci
porta ad accettare così la verità di
affermazioni del tipo ricordo bene la
grigliata abbiamo fatto il luglio scorso
oppure un testimone che può dire ricordo
di aver visto un uomo alto con i capelli
brizzolati e corti che stava spingendo
un carrello e noi crediamo nella verità
di questo tipo di formazioni
fondamentalmente crediamo nella
nel fatto che quando una persona
dice mi ricordo che quando una persona
dice vedo dice delle cose che sono parla
di cose che sono effettivamente accadute
e quindi noi abbiamo un senso della
realtà degli avvenimenti
che vengono raccontati che vengono
riportati anche dai testimoni ma questa
sensazione della realtà è una sensazione
che sta veramente in piedi una
sensazione che la ricerca in psicologia
dice essere giustificata ebbene la
ricerca in psicologia in realtà ha messo
in luce il fatto che non soltanto per
esempio la nostra memoria e fallace
perché noi dimentichiamo ma anche messo
in luce il fatto che la nostra memoria e
fallace perché noi ricordiamo delle cose
che non sono successe
questa idea che quello che ricordiamo è
vero è basata su una metafora che noi
abbiamo della memoria per cui la memoria
è fondamentalmente una videocamera che
registra dell'informazione e questa
informazione successivamente può essere
recuperata e la stessa cosa in realtà si
veniva detta anche anticamente da
aristotele che dice la memoria non è
altro che un sigillo che l'esperienza
lascia nella mente per cui ripercorrere
questo questo sigillo permette di
ripercorrere l'esperienza fatta ma in
realtà come dicevo la ricerca e memoria
dice che no i nostri ricordi non sono
assolutamente il ripercorrere
un'esperienza fatta i nostri ricordi
sono ricostruttivi e sono altamente
potenzialmente inaccurati
che cos'è che rende un ricordo
inaccurato
suggerimenti quello che ci viene detto
poi c'è un esempio di un esperimento
molto molto vecchio ma ce ne sono
centinaia di altri che ci dicono che per
esempio se certi termine che vengono
utilizzati all'interno delle domande
modifica non ricordo le persone che
hanno assistito all'incidente gente a
cui viene chiesto di dire il colore
delle auto che si sono toccate
frontalmente ricorderanno un incidente
di bassa media entità le persone a cui
si chiede la stessi fa la stessa domanda
ma si sostituisce il toccate
frontalmente con il scontrate
frontalmente
ricordano un incidente estremamente più
grave che cos'altro modifiche ai nostri
ricordi ricordo un incidente di questo
tipo cos'altro modifica i nostri ricordi
i nostri processi stessi di pensiero noi
ricordiamo
cause non viste noi vediamo un effetto e
inseriamo una causa ma poi ce la
ricordiamo come se l'avessimo vista
questo è un altro esperimento ancora
negli inizi degli anni 2000 venivano
presentate delle slide in cui c'era una
persona che faceva la spesa poi la spesa
accadeva in terra in modo rovinoso le
persone non soltanto ricordavano queste
slide che sarà state presentate ma
ricordavano anche delle slides che non
erano state presentate e che
rappresentavano il momento precedente
oppure la causa della caduta delle borse
della spesa e lo ricordavano e lo
ricordavano con certezza la stessa cosa
succede per esempio con le conseguenze
delle azioni noi ricordiamo delle
conseguenze non viste
ricordiamo per esempio
azioni
la piscina e di azioni che noi non
abbiamo visto se vediamo una donna che
prende una bottiglia d'acqua in realtà
ricordiamo non soltanto questa fase
dell'azione ma ricordiamo anche la donna
che beve dalla bottiglia anche se in
realtà non l'abbiamo mai vista e anche
se la donna invece di bere avrebbe
potuto tranquillamente versare l'acqua
nel bicchiere
quindi noi ricordiamo delle conseguenze
delle continuazione non viste di azioni
non soltanto ricordiamo
con creiamo ricordi
inaccurati in seguito a situazioni
sperimentali ma creiamo ricordo
inaccurati in modo spontaneo durante
l'infanzia troviamo una buona quantità
di ricordi inaccurate crediamo creiamo
ricordi inaccurati di tutta una serie di
situazioni che sono assolutamente
impossibili e anche in parte bizzarre
per esempio persone si ricordano è di
volare con le ali persone si ricordano
di essere inseguiti dai dinosauri
persone si ricordano di essere stati di
aver visto degli angeli gli angeli
questa volta con le ali tutte queste
cose sono cose oggettivamente
impossibile ma le persone anche se poi
diventano certe che naturalmente non
hanno fatto queste esperienze queste
cose le ricordano con grande accuratezza
e con grande dovizia di dettagli
la ricerca ha messo in piedi tutta una
serie di procedure sperimentali per
spiegare come le persone poi sviluppano
ricordi falsi in particolare la presenza
di materiale visivo fa sviluppare
ricordi falsi ma anche l'enel i racconti
che vengono fatti il sentito dire
e i pettegolezzi tutti questi elementi
creano anche loro ricordi farsi
e questo è un esempio va bene del motivo
per cui questi ricordi si creano perché
quando si parla quando si vedono
immagini in realtà uno si crea delle
immagini mentali queste immagini mentali
hanno delle caratteristiche tali da
essere scambiate per ricordi quindi per
elementi che si riferiscono ad
un'esperienza realmente fatta in questo
esperimento ad esempio avevamo fatto
abbiamo fatto immaginare dei soggetti
una situazione che non era mai accaduta
quella di un'infermiera che a scuola
aveva tagliato un pezzetto di pelle dal
dito mignolo per poter capire se c'era
stato contagio nucleare dopo chernobyl
ecco le persone una certa percentuale
delle persone hanno ricordato
questo avvenimento che non era
assolutamente mai caduto in quanto tale
a loro con dovizia di particolari per
esempio questo soggetto che diceva era
una stanza piccola e grigia c'era una
donna bionda c'era un forte odore di
disinfettante quindi anche con dettagli
anche dettagli sensoriali di una
situazione che non avevano vissuto
allora quindi questa idea che il ricordo
rappresenta un'esperienza vera è una
sensazione che in realtà è basata su un
nostro approccio necessario al mondo che
viene chiamato da alcune realismo
ingenuo cioè noi crediamo come diceva
bertrand russell che l'erba sia verde
che le pietre siano dure che la neve sia
fredda ecco questo come ci dicono i
fisici di per sé non è vero è
l'interazione del nostro sistema
sensoriale che ci permette di avere
questo tipo di percezione e questo
brevissimo esempio ce lo illustra noi
vediamo queste fragole rosse ma realtà
il colore delle fragole è esattamente
quello di questo quadratino che vedete
qua cioè sono grigio verdi e non
soltanto le fragole ma anche la striscia
sotto le fragole noi la vediamo rossa ma
se io copro le fragole quello che
vediamo è il colore del quadratino
inquadrati in scusa il colore della
striscia la striscia e grigia e anche se
copro con una maschera bianca la
striscia e grigia basta che io tolga le
fragole va bene
sono queste le nostre conoscenze che ci
impongono il colore che poi noi vediamo
quindi anche per la memoria in realtà
quello che guida questa nostra
sensazione che ricordo si riferisce
un'esperienza effettivamente fatta è in
fondo questo realismo ingenuo che ripeto
da una parte necessario dall'altra però
crea delle illusioni di realtà quando la
realtà in realtà non c'è e allora
appunto a cosa serve il pensiero
complesso in questi casi il pensiero
complesso quello che sottostà alla
ricerca in psicologia e poi anche alla
ricerca nelle neuroscienze per capire
come effettivamente il nostro sistema
umano cognitivo il nostro sistema di
memoria funziona quindi noi sappiamo che
i ricordi di base necessarie inter
fretta la realtà non per nulla siamo in
grado di negoziare la realtà con
successo tutti i giorni ma in realtà i
nostri ricordi non sono mai totalmente
accurati ai nostri ricordi qualche volta
sono anche completamente falsi perché
allora questi ricordi inaccurati e falsi
questi ricordi inaccurati e falsi
dipendono dal fatto che il sistema
cognitivo umano fondamentalmente è
preposto a dare senso all'esperienza
dell'oggi e a predire il futuro e allora
ha bisogno del passato naturalmente per
dare questo senso di continuità e di
stabilità e di esperienza precedente ma
ha bisogno anche di negoziare il
presente quindi di adattarsi al presente
quindi deve essere flessibile e questa
flessibilità e quella che produce gli
errori di memoria e quindi queste
illusioni questi errori di memoria sono
normali sono naturali sono parte del
sono il risultato di come funziona il
sistema cognitivo umano e sono in un
qualche modo anche necessari sono
necessari perché per l'appunto
permettono all'uomo di vivere il qui e
ora
utilizzando il passato ma tenendo molto
presente anche le proprie esigenze e
proprio scopo del momento l'unico
problema è nella testimonianza nella
testimonianza dove in realtà il ricordo
deve essere accurato e corrispondere a
verità ma lo sarà mai